dinglerin is the new fide world champion
the First new champion in a decade in
the final Winner Takes all tie breaks
the players split three tenths and well
fought draws before reaching the final
rapid tiebreak game it too appeared to
be headed for a draw would we get the
first Blitz tie breaks in a world
championship ever the answer was no
first ding played a brilliant move in
Queen E2 keeping an extra Pawn Jan met
this by repeating checks and the
commentators began to guarantee a draw
by repetition when ding shocked the
Chess World by stepping into a pin with
Rook G6 this risky strategy paid off
quickly as Jon aired and ding surged
forward first with his past sea pawn and
then with his past a pawn hundreds of
thousands of people watched as with
seconds on the clock and a world
championship on the line Dean pushed
through emotionally claiming the title
for himself and for the first time for
China